♪ ♪
>> Will: LIKE COMMUNIST CHINA
IN THE 1960s, WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A CULTURAL REVOLUTION
HERE IN AMERICA.
IT'S REVOLUTION WHOSE BATTLES
ARE BEING FOUGHT ON TWO FRONTS.
THE CLASSROOM AND IN YOUR HR
DEPARTMENT.
SOMEHOW VIRGINIA HAS BECOME THE
LEXINGTON AND CONCORD OF THIS
REVOLUTION EVERY WEEK.
THERE IS A NEW VIDEO OF PARENTS
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST RADICAL
TRANSGENDER AND RACE POLICIES.
[SCREAMING]
♪♪ FOR THE LAND OF THE FREE ♪
♪ AND THE HOME OF THE BRAVE ♪♪
DO YOUR JOB!
[INAUDIBLE]
>> PLEASE ARREST THIS INDIVIDUAL
FOR TRESPASSING.
WHAT DID I DO WRONG?
>> Will: GREG GUTFELD IS A
HOST OF THE GOT FILLED SHOW.
HE IS WITH US TONIGHT.
READ, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING?
I THINK YOU ARE SEEING THE NEW
RADICALS.
THEY ARE LIKE GRANDPARENTS.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE A
LOT TO LOSE WITH CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN AN IDEOLOGY
BURNED SO QUICKLY THROUGH
SOCIETY.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO IS BEHIND
IT, WHERE IT IS HAPPENING.
THEY HAVE A FEW TALKING HEADS, A
FEW AUTHORS.
THE JOINT CHIEF OF STAFF,
JANITOR MARK MILLEY IS SENDING
IT TO TROOPS BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
UNDERSTAND WHITE RACE PIER WHEN
YOU NOW HAVE THAT IN THE MILITA,
THIS WAR, WE ARE LOSING IT.
YOU HAVE YOUR OWN MILITARY
ADOPTING WHAT IS PRETTY MUCH A
RACIST THEOLOGY.
AND NOW YOU ARE LOOKING AT ALL
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THAT,
THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO LOSE
CHRIS TO GO EXACTLY.
BUT WHEN ONCE YOU HAVE SOMETHING
TO LOSE, THAT'S WHEN YOU HAVE A
TEA PARTY.
THAT'S WHEN YOU HAVE OCCUPY
WALL STREET.
THIS IS THE NEXT ONE.
AND IT'S GOING TO CUT ACROSS ALL
PARTY LINES.
THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO LOSE,
IT'S THEIR CHILDREN, THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS.
I MENTIONED BEFORE THEY ARE TWO
BATTLE FRONTS IN THIS CULTURAL
REVOLUTION.
EVERYONE WATCHING DEALS WITH
THAT IF YOU WORK FOR A
CORPORATION UNDERSTANDS THAT
YOUR HR DEPARTMENT IS THE OTHER
BATTLEFRONT.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE MANDATORY DI
TRAINING.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, BY THE
WAY, A LADY NAMED KAREN WAS
APPROVED TO RUN THE OFFICE OF
PERSONNEL.
THAT IS LIKE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S HR DEPARTMENT AND
THE G.O.P. IS POINTING OUT THAT
SHE HAD TIES TO CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
>> HERE'S THE THING.
HERE'S WHERE I WAS WRONG MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
I THOUGHT ALL OF THE IDIOTS ON
CAMPUSES STAYING IN THE CAMPUS.
IT DOESN'T MOVE INTO THE REAL
WORLD.
BUT I WAS WRONG.
IT HAS MOVED INTO THE HR
DEPARTMENT.
EVERYWHERE.
WHEN YOU GET THE EMAIL WITH THE
LANGUAGE, THE EQUITY, THE WOKE
STUFF, YOU REALIZE, MY GOD, IT'S
HERE.
WHY IS IT HERE?
LAWYERS, PROTECTION.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GET SUED FOR
ANY KIND OF HARASSMENT.
THEY WANT TO SAY ALL THE RIGHT
THINGS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE ACCUSED OF
BIGOTRY.
AND IT PROVIDES CORPORATIONS
COVER, RIGHT?
SO MAYBE IF YOU ARE MAKING SHOES
IN CHINA BUT YOU SAY ALL THE
RIGHT STUFF IN YOUR HR
DEPARTMENT --
ACTUALLY, THEY ARE, THE LEFT
WOULD FIGHT CORPORATIONS.
NOW THEY ARE OKAY IF YOU USE THE
RIGHT PRONOUNS.
THEY ARE BEING PLAYED FOR
SUCKERS.
>> Will: I'M THE SAME AS YOU.
I USED TO THINK THAT COLLEGE WAS
THIS LACK OF REAL-WORLD
EXPERIENCE.
IT WOULD PUT KIDS OUT IN THE
REAL WORLD AND THEY WOULD BE
SHOCKED.
NO, WHAT HAPPENED AS THEY CHANGE
THE REAL RULES.
THEY TOOK IT OVER.
>> NOTHING LIKE THIS I'VE EVER
SEEN.
IT'S GOING TO BE THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE WANT TO STOP IT.
IT AIN'T GOING TO BE US.
IT'S GOING TO BE THEM.
>> Will: WATCH DOMINIC WAT